das ist Hasan ferusi seine Tochter ist
18 Tage alt als er festgenommen wird er
wurde zum Tode verurteilt weil er
demonstriert hat schwer gefoltert kam er
zeitweilig ins Krankenhaus und sendete
eine Botschaft
mein letzter Wunsch ist es meine Tochter
noch einmal zu sehen
der Bundestagsabgeordnete Johann
wade-pfuhl hat die politische
Patenschaft für Hasan ferosi übernommen
und setzt sich für seine Freilassung ein
dieses Regime hat jede Legalität und
Legitimität im Volk verloren und jetzt
versucht es sich mit mittelalterlichen
Methoden an der Macht zu halten das ist
nicht akzeptabel und darauf mache ich
aufmerksam und ich dränge auch darauf
dass Deutschland insgesamt mehr
politische Konsequenzen zieht
290 deutsche Abgeordnete haben
inzwischen Patenschaften übernommen
schreiben Briefe appellieren Posten in
den sozialen Netzwerken die Namen und
Schicksale der Inhaftierten in Iran
die Deutsch-Iranerin daniela seperia hat
diese politischen Patenschaften mit
organisiert
ein Name der bekannt ist ist ein Name
den das Regime nicht so schnell
verschwinden lassen kann
ohne uns und fürchten zu müssen
der hingerichtet worden ist war ein Name
den niemand kannte Abgeordnete aus dem
Bundestag aber auch aus Landtagen oder
dem Europaparlament machen mit jeden Tag
mehr eine der ersten war Yvonne Rey sie
setzt sich für den iranischen Rapper too
much Salehi ein bekannt für seine offene
Kritik am Regime und im Iran ein
volksfeld seit mehr als 70 Tagen ist er
in Einzelhaft angeklagt wegen Korruption
auf Erden und Krieg gegen Gott auf
beides steht die Todesstrafe
ich habe den Botschafter geschrieben ich
habe Annalena baerbock als
Außenministerin geschrieben und der
Menschenrechtsbeauftragten der
Bundesregierung habe auf seinen
Schicksal aufmerksam gemacht und gesagt
dass ich schon erwarte dass Thomas
und falls er nicht frei kommt zumindest
einen rechtmäßiges Verfahren bekommt in
Schauprozessen ohne Anwalt werden
demonstrierende in Iran abgeurteilt auch
Mohammad Robert der 22-Jährige ist zum
Tode verurteilt er ist in Isolationshaft
könnte jeden Tag hingerichtet werden
seine Mutter beteuert vor dem Gefängnis
seine Unschuld
tausende Kilometer entfernt versucht
Bundestagsabgeordnete Klara Bünger ihm
zu helfen auf sein Schicksal aufmerksam
zu machen das Verfahren was gegen ihn
geführt wurde wurde da wurde innerhalb
eines Tages das Todesurteil gefällt und
das macht eigentlich die Willkür des
Regimes deutlich und auch wie quasi wie
unrechtmäßig diese Verfahren abgelaufen
sind und trotzdem machen die Menschen in
Iran weiter
Demonstrationen hier in der Stadt seihe
doch
und auch in Deutschland bleiben sie
weiter laut
bekannte jetzt inhaftierte
Rapper zu beachten und das gilt hier
auch Verbrechen sind im totenwinkel
unsichtbar wir müssen hinsehen um
Schlimmeres zu vermeiden das Video wie
eine böse Vorahnung Thomas solleh soll
im Gefängnis so schwer gefoltert worden
sein dass er sein Augenlicht verlieren
könnte doch seine Botschaft wird
weitergehört